monday edition of pftot where we get to
some of the things we were able to get
to during the program and how about this
from hall of fame receiver michael irvin
and a huge supporter still of the dallas
cowboys despite the fact that he works
for nfl network and should have some
degree of neutrality i respect the fact
that he makes no bones about it he's
still all in with the council
he recently made the argument that the
cowboys
should pay him
in part for the fact
that for four years
they got away with not paying him
anything you got him in the fourth round
you stole four years so whatever he gets
he deserves because you still owe him
back pay and
uh look that's not how the system works
but i there's some there's some basic
merit in the idea that the cowboys have
had the benefit of a great quarterback
for four years and they didn't pay him
very much at all in relation to what
other teams are paying their
quarterbacks for the kind of performance
they've enjoyed chris
yeah no i mean all right so there's two
things i think that popped in my brain
with this first off michael irvin like
you said he's still very entrenched with
the dallas cowboys organization the
jones family i mean we see games where
he's up there in the luxury box you know
slapping them high five and doing stuff
like that so i i was first off shocked
that he kind of took that stance to put
more pressure on the cowboys
organization to pay dak prescott you
know two
you know the other thing that jumps out
to me i mean he's right yes but like i'm
more error on to like what you said
that's not how the system works listen
doc prescott should be paid really
handsomely because
he's one of the 10 best quarterbacks in
football and he deserves to be paid in
in that upper echelons at the position
that's why he should be paid that type
of money so you can't go back and pay
guys you know for what they have done
and all that you know the cowboys could
also argue hey doc nobody drafted you in
the first four rounds we did so you know
there's something to that too
but i totally understand michael urban's
you know point there i do get that and
now the again i just where is this dak
prescott conversation i don't i don't
know you know i know i've heard some
things out there and some numbers i've
also heard you know dr prescott's agent
got pissed at me when he heard me say
some of those numbers so i don't know
really where they're at in this this uh
bargaining right now but either way dak
prescott deserves to be paid
every bit in the jared goff class of
quarterbacks or whatever it may be there
well here's where it stands they have
until july 15 to do a long-term deal if
not they can only do a one-year contract
for 2020 and he's guaranteed to make
31.4 million dollars unless they rescind
the franchise tender stephen jones told
me several weeks ago they are not going
to do it that's not binding they could
change their mind and if they were to
rescind the franchise tender in oh i
don't know mid-august it's not like
somebody else is going to give dak
prescott 31.4 million dollars for the
2020 season so they do have a nuclear
option that they're not willing to use
assuming that they won't use it he's
looking at 31.4 million this year a 20
raise next year we've done the math
before
69.08 million over the next two years if
it goes year to year under the franchise
tag and then 2022 is the kirk cousins
dilemma for the cowboys a 44 raise which
is 54.25 million if they use the
franchise tag a third time a 20 raise if
they would use the transition tag and
have a right of first refusal which
would be more than 45 million for that
third year or let him walk away he's
holding all the cards here under the
same system
that allowed the cowboys to pay him
peanuts
for the first four years of his career
see that's the difference
and that's where michael irvin's point
in my mind falls apart the cowboys have
taken full advantage of their rights
under the system and now dak prescott is
in position to take full advantage of
his rights and when you're not a first
round pick
you get to the market after four years
and in many respects that's far more
value to dak prescott than if he had
been
a first-round pick so
look and that's why i support that
prescott's effort to get whatever it is
that here's what it comes down to chris
he has this ability as we've just
articulated 31.4 this year
another 37 million plus next year and
then maybe a shot at the open market
what will the cowboys offer him by way
of a long-term deal to get him to
surrender the bird in the hand and it's
one hell of a bird in the hand that has
grown fat on the seeds of delay because
the cowboys have waited too long to sign
him he's holding all the cards now
that's what people don't realize
yeah no yeah i mean you're right he
holds all the cards um you you would
think that he's gonna have to get some
sort of
you know guaranteed at signing
a number north of 70 something million
dollars because like you said it's 69
million if he plays the franchise game
the next two years so they better come
strong with that and i think more to
what michael irving is saying more than
anything is back k whatever it may be
he's just i think more than anything
saying to the dallas cowboys like for
everything this guy has done
through the start of his career for your
organization
i think he wants to tell jerry jones and
the cowboys let's not like penny pinch
over four or five million dollars and
have that be the reason that dak
prescott's not signed to a long-term
deal or something like that i think
that's probably what michael irving was
trying to say more than anything is that
he's earned the right for the cowboys to
squash the beef over that little extra
bit of money or whatever it may be now
if it's a huge large sum amount you know
that's they're like 25 30 million
dollars i don't know that's a different
ball game but if the gap is close i
think michael irvin that's what he's
probably trying to say is like let's not
penny pinch here the guy's been a steal
for your football team the last few
years and let's just pony up that money
and move on and try to build a team
around them
and chris the bottom line is this the
cowboys benefited from the system for
four years and now they don't want to
follow the system they want dak prescott
to do a team friendly deal to take less
to help have other guys around and
he's not required to do that he doesn't
have to be tom brady if he doesn't want
to be tom brady remember the side eye he
gave you when you started talking in
terms of team friendly deal he's not
required to do it the system favors him
now the system screwed him 2016 17 18
19. now the pendulum has swung in dak
press god's favor and
no deal it's funny because
we were talking on friday big cat and i
about the fact that dak prescott's
contributing a million dollars to
efforts up
related to
ending police brutality and education
and advocacy for the issues that have
the the nation uh so engaged right now
and big cat said hey oh do you does that
mean he's getting a contract soon i said
he's getting 31.4 million this year even
he doesn't get a contract he's going to
be fine this year and the question is
and this is very simple it it could
apply to any of us anything you have
that you might sell let's say you got an
old car you want to sell what does it
take for you to part with the car what
does it take for you to sell your house
what does it take for you to sell
whatever it is that you may be thinking
about selling and what he's selling is
the ability to make 69 million over the
next two years plus the ability to put
the cowboys way over a barrel in 2022.
either 45 million with a right to match
what someone else offers 54 million if
they franchise tag him or he walks away
to the highest bidder or the cowboys
have to match or beat the highest bidder
he has the power here and the big reason
he's got the power chris is because the
cowboys waited too
long to get this taken care of that's
the lesson that every other team should
learn from this the minute the window
opens on signing that quarterback to a
second contract and it opens as soon as
the third regular season ends not the
postseason not free agency not the draft
as soon as and there's a stunning number
of people who have jobs in the nfl with
nfl teams who don't realize this the cba
says that you can sign that second
contract the moment the regular season
for the third year ends and that's what
you need to do because you're going to
get him cheaper than
a lot cheaper than than what you're
going to get him later well you're in
you're getting them when they're
desperate you know i could speak to this
i mean gosh i kind of was in this
scenario to a degree
but if i was in it where okay i'm in the
franchise conversation or you know oh a
team came to me you know you're three of
my nfl career we went to the playoffs i
was the starting quarterback for the
bucks all that you know if that was the
year the bucks came to me with like a
substantial long-term offer that was
probably below like market price
you know as a player
you go damn you know listen i haven't
made a ton of money in my first two
years in the league whoa you're going to
give me that much guaranteed at signing
i know that's a lot less than the other
starting quarterbacks or the top market
guys but damn i haven't had money like
that i'll take it that's a guarantee now
if i get hurt i don't have to worry
about anything like that so teams really
could gain a lot of leverage on the
situation by taking the approach you're
talking about mike and then you know
lastly i do want to just point out that
was an amazing um
donation by by dak prescott i think
again i think this speaks volumes to
what this guy is you know he's talented
on the field but it just shows what type
of leader he is too and mike what's he
made in his career to this point i know
he's making 31 million this year but he
doesn't have that in the bank yet he's
not getting checked for that he's made
what like 4 million maybe total his
career to this point something like that
so to give this type of
football money right he's doing he's
doing well with the with the
non-football money too but still a
million dollars and and look folks you
got to make about
what 1.7 1.8 to write a check for a
million dollars right i mean it's after
tax money it's not pre-tax money and
they've they've the deductions have
changed in recent years too you it's a
lot it's it's a lot more than a million
dollars you have to earn in order to
give a million dollars
yes and that that you know to me that
just that's an unbelievable thing that
he's doing and i do i do want to give
him credit for that you know that's
that's a huge substantial amount of
money i haven't heard too many players
donating that type of money and most of
the players that are donating big money
already had
you know tens and tens of millions in
the bank already you know these are
people that are doing you know i don't
want to bring up names and we've heard
other players and quarterbacks five
hundred thousand dollars this that that
and i'm gonna go man well yeah they've
made 70 80 million dollars this is a guy
that's you know hasn't even stretched
out his bank account yet to make that
kind of commitment is big time and i
think speaks to the leader he is you
know and uh i think that's why he is the
franchise for the dallas cowboys and i
don't know mike i just don't know where
this goes again you don't hear any
rumors a lot of rumors about this
conversation in general
there's no reason july 15 right yeah
after fourth of july after that holiday
that's when they get down to business
there's no reason here's why you don't
negotiate now because if you get close
to your bottom line now the other side's
going to disengage and say let's take it
up on july 13. and if you get close to
your bottom line now you're going to get
squeezed off of it later that's why
deadlines drive action because
that's when you land the plane that's
when both sides come together with the
two circles of the venn diagram all i
have to do is touch all they have to do
is kiss and you get a deal done if you
go prematurely sometimes you end up
getting squeezed off of what it is that
you're either willing to pay or willing
to accept let me let me make one last
point before we end this because when
you were playing
uh
a team could redo a deal with a draft
pick after two seasons now it's three
that's part of the 2011 adjustment to
the cba and it's still in place today
three years before you can redo the deal
you made it to the playoffs your third
season
under today's standards the buccaneers
could have come to you after week 17
and before the playoff game before you
play that one more game that high
intensity game that game where the risk
of injury is greater
that's the time to offer the guy the big
contract that's the time to put it on
the table and look and look maybe maybe
his agent says don't do it don't do it
let's wait let's wait but if you're the
player
and they're coming to you and they're
saying this is the earliest we're
allowed to sign you to a new contract we
don't want to wait we don't want to
delay this is what we believe you have
earned through your play the first three
years and we'd like to sign you to this
contract right now it's a pretty good
chance the guy's going to take it
i agree a hundred percent you're i mean
you're right you know guys in my
scenario too
being a third rounder you know whatever
it may be and let's be real about this
situation you know i i came from a
household of money and things like that
too i've been i was fortunate so why
can't i care
silver spoon diamond encrusted whatever
the hell you want to say okay all right
mean streets of greenwich
well at that time it was franklin lakes
new jersey i know but i know but the guy
the guy the guy who the guy who coined
the phrase fair upbringing was raised on
the mean streets of greenwich
connecticut
very very very true very true but yeah
you know i mean yes if that type of
money was dangled out in front of me to
where you're going to go whoa you're
going to give me this much at signing
and i'm going to make this much on a
year-to-year basis yeah i'm i'm taking
it i am and you know i think most
players in football would it's still a
brutal brutally physical sport you you
realize if you're smart that it can all
end in a in a snap and a flash it really
can and i'm i'm prime example so uh i
don't think teams take advantage of that
enough mike i think too many of them to
what you're saying put it off on the
back burner and go well we don't need to
do it right now we have some more time
to wait this out and what they do in
that more times than not is wait it out
and the price goes up like you're saying
and then they they can't afford to keep
the guy where if they just got in early
they probably could keep him and a few
other guys that could be staples to
their organization
july 15 is the target they either get it
done or they don't and here's the thing
to remember if they don't get it done
one the cowboys can rescind the
franchise tender even though they said
they won't and number two he's under no
obligation to show up for training camp
to show up for the preseason he can do
what le'veon bell did and just blow into
town
five six days before the first game of
the regular season if he wants to and
people would say well why at that point
it doesn't matter well what you can do
even though you can't do a multi-year
deal after july 15 you can still
negotiate different terms of a one-year
deal whether it's more money or whether
it's a promise that next year we won't
use the franchise tag and we've seen
teams do that with guys like i think
lance briggs albert haynesworth so you
withhold services to get something and
after july 15 what dak prescott can get
by withholding services is a commitment
that next year no franchise tag for dak
prescott and he becomes a free agent we
see we find out look well i don't know
what he's worth on the open market the
cowboys have elected to pay him 31.4
million this year to prevent him from
finding out and prevent the rest of us
from finding out what he could get on
the open market so uh maybe we'll find
out next year or the year after for now
though put a pin in it july 15 they
either get it done or they don't we've
gotten it done chris as i said at the
end of the show i'm having birthday cake
for breakfast for lunch for dinner and
maybe for a couple of meals in between
i'll work out later this week to make up
for it all right go for it you earned it
happy birthday man double double fives
baby double nickel 55 years old mike
foreo baby happy birthday
everybody have a great day see you
tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports